>> Laura: THE MAN WHO IS
REALLY LEAD AND GALVANIZE THE
G.O.P.'S EFFORTS TO RALLY BEHIND
JUDGE KAVANAUGH'S LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
ONE WEEK AFTER HIS FIERY CALL TO
ARMS, I LOVED IT!
THE SENATOR IS FEELING MORE
CONFIDENT THAN AFTER AFTER
READING THE FBI REPORT ON BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
SENATOR GRAHAM JOINS US HOW TO
TALK ABOUT THAT AND WHAT IS
NEXT, SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT OTHER GAMES CAN WE EXPECT
FROM THE DEMOCRATS BEFORE THIS
THING GOES TO THE FINAL VOTE?
>> THEY WILL DO IT.
IF THEY COULD WRITE A BOOK ABOUT
OVERPLAYING THEIR HANDS IN
POLITICS, THIS ISN'T THE FIRST
CHAPTER.
THE FBI REPORTS, THE BACKGROUND
INTERVIEWED NINE PEOPLE.
THEY FOLLOW THE DIRECTION OF THE
THREE SENATORS WHO ASKED FOR
MORE INVESTIGATION.
IT CAME BACK VERY GOOD FOR JUDGE
KAVANAUGH AND NOW I WOULD EXPECT
HE SENATORS TO VOTE YES.
I HOPE THEY WILL BECAUSE THAT IS
WHAT THEY ASKED FOR.
>> Laura: THE COMPLAINT FROM
THE LEFT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM.
WE HAVE A FEW SENATORS, A FEW OF
YOUR FRIENDS AND OTHERS WHO
COMMENTED TODAY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IT IS OBVIOUSLY A COVER-UP.
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE WORKING
WITH THE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
IN THE SENATE HAVE DELIBERATELY
CIRCUMSCRIBED THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THEY'RE MAKING A MOCKERY OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL CLIMATE.
SPEAK UP THAT IS NOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION IT IS A
INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: THEY DIDN'T
INTERVIEW HER COUSIN SECOND
TWICE REMOVED.
>> THIS IS YOUR VIEW OF THE
SENATE'S ROLE IS TO TAKE A GOOD
MAN'S LIFE AND TURN IT UPSIDE
DOWN, BETRAY DR. FORD'S TRUST.
DO EVERYTHING IN THE WORLD TO
DESTROY HIM.
THAT DOES NOT ADVISE CONSENTS
THAT IS DESPICABLE.
IT IS GOING TO BLOW UP IN YOUR
FACE.
I HOPE IT DOES BECAUSE IF IT
GOES WRONG HE WILL GET ON THE
COURT.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA OF WHAT THE
FBI SUPPLEMENTED INVESTIGATION
WAS ABOUT.
THEY MADE UP THEIR MINDS TO VOTE
NO BEFORE ANYONE SAID NO.
HEAR WHAT THEY ASKED FOR, THEY
ASKED THAT THE PEOPLE WHO NAMED
HER GOT INTERVIEWED AND
MISS RAMIREZ BE INTERVIEWED.
THAT WAS DONE PLUS FOUR, FIVE
OTHER WITNESSES.
THE RESULTS ARE IN.
SENATOR COLLINS AND
SENATOR FLAKE BUT IT WAS
THOROUGH.
THE THOUGHT IT WAS FAIR.
THESE TWO PEOPLE ARE MY FRIENDS
AND THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHO THEY
TALK ABOUT.
>> Laura: SENATOR SCHUMER
TALKED ABOUT THE EMOTION THAT
DROVE CHRISTINE FORD IN THE
COUNTRY RALLYING BEHIND HER, IT
SEEMS LIKE HE IS TAKEN THIS IN A
MIDTERM POSE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> DR. FORD CAME FORWARD AND ONE
AMERICA'S HEARTS.
A REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WERE
UPSET THAT THAT MIGHT DERAIL
THEIR HEADLONG RUSH TO PUT JUDGE
KAVANAUGH ON THE SUPREME COURT.
>> Laura: THE HEADLONG RUSH?
YOU'RE RUSHING THIS BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO GET IT DONE AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE.
THIS WAS EMOTIONALLY BASED AND
USED BY THOSE PROTESTERS TODAY
ON CAPITOL HILL, A LOT OF WOMEN.
THEY TOOK OVER THE OFFICE
BUILDING FOR I DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG.
THEY PROMISE THAT THEY WERE
GONNA KEEP DOING THIS.
THEY ARE GOING TO KEEP TACKLING
YOU GUYS IN ELEVATORS AND
QUARTERING YOU IN THE HALLS.
THE PROTEST CULTURE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE.
>> IT WON'T WORK FOR ME.
I THINK MY COLLEAGUES FEEL
OFFENDED AS DOES
SENATOR SCHUMER.
I'VE NEVER BEEN MORE
DISAPPOINTED IN YOU AND YOUR
PARTY.
SHE REQUESTED TO REMAIN
ANONYMOUS, IT WAS SOMEBODY ON
YOUR SIDE WHO LEAKED IT TO THE
PRESS FOR POLITICAL PURPOSE.
HER OWN LAWYERS WHO WERE ADVISED
TO BE APPOINTED BY
SENATOR FEINSTEIN, THE MOST
CLINICALLY ACTIVE PERSON
APPARENTLY NEVER TOLD DR. FORD
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
CALIFORNIA TO AVOID ANY
EMBARRASSMENT.
PLEASE DON'T USE AND ABUSE HIS
WOMAN ANYMORE.
HER ACCUSATIONS HAVE NOT BEEN
COOPERATED.
WE DON'T KNOW ANYMORE THAN WE
DID BEFORE.
THE PEOPLE SHE NAMED, THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT SHE'S TALKING ABOUT.
IT REALLY OFFENDS ME THAT
SENATOR SCHUMER WOULD CONTINUE
TO ABUSE DR. FORD.
THEY ARE THE ONES WERE PLAYING
POLITICS.
I VOTED, NEVER THOUGHT TWICE
ABOUT IT.
I TELL YOU RIGHT NOW, THIS IS A
DEFINING MOMENT FOR THE 2018
ELECTION.
THIS IS UNFAIR.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK ABOUT
REPERCUSSIONS FOR WHAT HAPPENS.
HE DID THE FILING OF FALSE
EVIDENCE, THAT CAN BE PROVED.
WHAT ABOUT TO THIS LEAKING
ISSUE, WE TALK ABOUT ON THE SHO
SHOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE SOMEONE IS NOT
TELLING THE TRUTH HERE ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED ON THE SENATE'S
SIDE.
DO YOU THINK WHAT DIANE
FEINSTEIN SAID WHEN SHE SAID, I
DIDN'T ASK ANYBODY AND THEN SHE
SAID, OH, NO, THEY TELL ME I DID
ASK THEM.
NO ONE ON MY STAFF LEAKS IT.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> I BELIEVE THAT SHE DIDN'T
ONLY GET BETTER KNOW ABOUT HER
STAFF.
I DO KNOW THIS, OR STAFF
RECOMMENDED TO DR. FORD WHO
HATES TRUMP AND IS A POLITICALLY
ACTIVIST LAWYER, APPARENTLY
DR. FORD WAS NOT TOLD BY HER
LEGAL TEAM.
SOMEBODY ON THEIR SIDE LEAKED
ANONYMOUS LETTER WITHOUT --
>> Laura: SO ARE NOT SECURE
THE EMAILS ON THEIR TAX?
>> HERE IS WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
ANYBODY WHO DID THIS IS GOING TO
PAY A PRICE.
THE PEOPLE WHO EXPOSED MY NAME,
SENATOR HATCH.
THAT PERSON IS GOING TO PAY A
PRICE.
MY GOAL IF I AM CHAIRMAN IS TO
MAKE SURE NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
THE BEST WAY TO MEASURE NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN IS TO PUNISH THOSE
WHO DID IT.
>> Laura: WHAT LESSON YOU
THINK THE PRESIDENT SHOULD TAKE
OUT OF ALL THIS?
THIS WAS A MOMENT, THE PARTY GOT
UNIFIED.
THE ECONOMY IS ON FIRE.
GREAT JUDGES.
NAFTA WAS RENEGOTIATED.
WHAT IS NEXT?
>> THE PRESIDENT SHOULD TAKE THE
FOLLOWING, IF YOU APPOINT A GOOD
PERSON WHO GETS DESTROYED IN A
DESPICABLE MANNER AND YOU FIGHT
FOR HIM, PEOPLE WILL LIKE YOU
MORE.
WHETHER YOU ARE TRUMP REPUBLICAN
OR BUSH REPUBLICAN, LIBERTARIAN
OR VEGETARIAN REPUBLICAN.
WE ARE ALL TOGETHER NOW THANKS
TO THIS DESPICABLE ATTACK ON A
GOOD MAN.
HERE'S WHAT I WANT THE PRESIDENT
TO KNOW.
DO THE RIGHT THING AND FIGHT FOR
IT AND YOU WILL GET REWARDED.
CAVANAGH WILL BE ON THE BENCH.
THOSE WHO TRY TO DESTROY HIM ARE
GOING TO BE LOOKED AT AND THEY
ARE GOING TO PAY A PRICE.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO HELP US
IN THE MIDTERMS.
I HATE THAT THIS IS WHAT IT TOOK
TO HELP REPUBLICANS.
TO THE OTHER SIDE, YOU MADE THE
BIGGEST MISTAKE OF YOUR LIFE.
TO  TO THE THREE REPUBLICANS, YO
TO  TO THE THREE REPUBLICANS, YU
WERE ALL FRIENDS OF MINE, PLEASE
BE GUESSED NOW.
EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM, JUDGE
KAVANAUGH HE IS A GOOD MAN.
SEVEN FBI INVESTIGATIONS.
HUNDRED AND 56 PEOPLE.
ALL OF THE STUFF IS GARBAGE.
>> Laura: YOUR MANAGER BACK IN
1998, I REMEMBER IT WELL,
DEMOCRATS ARE PLEDGING THAT IF
THEY TAKE THE HOUSE THEY COULD
VERY WELL MOVE TO IMPEACH BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
GETTING HIM CONVICTED WILL BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO DO, DO YOU
EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN IF
REPUBLICANS LOSE THE HOUSE AND
KEEP THIS SAGA GOING?
>> I THINK THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAS BEEN TAKEN OVER BY
RATIONALITY, HATRED IS THERE
ONLY PLATFORM.
IT IS NOT ABOUT WHO THEY LIKE IT
IS ABOUT WHO THEY HATE.
THE THOUGHT THAT YOU ARE GUILTY
JUST BY THE ACCUSATION.
IF A DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE WERE
TREATED BY THE REPUBLICANS AS
BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS TREATED BY
THE DEMOCRATS, EVERYONE BE UP IN
ARMS.
JOE MANCHIN, WILL HE VOTE YES?
>> IF YOU LISTENS TO THE PEOPLE
OF WEST VIRGINIA HE WILL.
BRETT DESERVES YOUR VOTE JOE.
HE IS MY FRIEND, I'VE KNOWN HIM